merci Jean-Pierre cher de nous
accompagner pendant cette demi-heure
vous êtes sénateur du Loiret sénateur
socialiste du Loiret questeur du Sénat
on va évidemment revenir longuement sur
cette interview d'Emmanuel Macron qui
n'a donc pas reculé sur la réforme des
retraites il estime que la réforme est
nécessaire et je le cite qu'il n'y a pas
36 solutions est-ce que le combat
politique est perdu pour vous
le combat politique n'est jamais perdu
cher Oriane mansini jamais et je voulais
vous dire que comme beaucoup de Français
finalement moi je suis allé avant 13h
manger rapidement une part de quiche en
me disant il faut pas que je manque ce
rendez-vous donc j'étais là à 13h devant
mon écran je me suis dit il va quand
même annoncer quelque chose et puis à
13h30 j'étais toujours là finalement
ça donne le sentiment d'un homme qui est
immobile qui est dans ses convictions et
qui pense que les choses sont bien acier
ne pourrait pas être autrement et je
déplore cela voyez-vous à la fin de
l'interview il a parlé d'une
contribution exceptionnelle des
entreprises je me suis dit ah
pendant le débat aussi bien l'Assemblée
nationale
caussée là surtout au Sénat nous avons
parlé mais je ne des quantités de foi
de tous les moyens qu'il pourrait y
avoir pour contribuer à cette réforme
notamment des super profits des
entreprises qui gagnent des milliards et
des milliards parce qu'il y a la guerre
en Ukraine et la réponse a été non nous
ne voulons pas augmenter les impôts et
nous avons dit oui mais les impôts de
quelqu'un qui ne gagnent pas beaucoup
c'est pas pareil que les super profits
et là tout d'un coup alors que c'est
fini il dit ça c'est fini ou
provisoirement il dit voilà il faudrait
une taxe exceptionnelle mais pas sur les
super profils taxe exceptionnelle on
sait pas très bien sur quoi j'ai trouvé
que c'était assez pitoyable parce que
dans ce cas-là
qui font tellement de revenus ils en
arrivent à racheter leur propre action
au final c'est pas une bonne nouvelle
pour vous cette contribution
exceptionnelle pourquoi pendant le débat
au Sénat alors que nous avons proposé
par exemple Monique Lubin ma collègue
dix fois 20 fois cela pourquoi
la balle n'a-t-elle pas été saisie il
aurait ça aurait été tellement bien
qu'il y ait quand même quelques signes
d'écoute et moi écoutez j'ai été frappé
aussi je dois vous le dire pendant tout
ce débats par un certain amatourisme
voyez-vous on nous a dit voilà il va y
avoir une retraite à minimum au début on
a pensé tous et toutes que tout le monde
allait que tous les retraités allaient
toucher au minimum avec carrière
complète et puis le temps a passé plus
on s'est rendu compte que ça se
réduisait comme une voix de chagrin à la
fin on ne sait même pas si 20000
personnes vont toucher cela de même les
carrières longues si vous avez compris
ce qui se passe pour les gens qui ont
commencé à travailler à 16 ans à 17 ans
à 18 ans à 19 ans à 20 ans je vous
félicite parce que c'était d'une d'une
absence de clarté autrement dit d'une
obscurité très grande donc je trouve que
ce n'était pas bien préparé et en même
temps il y avait une rigidité il y a
toujours une rigidité
vous l'avez trouvé vous avez trouvé
rigide j'ai trouvé que rien ne change
comme si le président était enfermé dans
ses convictions et moi j'ai pensé que
bien avant en tant que président de la
République il aurait dû prendre
peut-être l'initiative par exemple les
syndicats ont demandé à être reçu c'est
quand même pas scandaleux alors que tous
les syndicats sont uniques il y a ce
mouvement social d'une Force Extrême que
le président les reçoit par exemple il
se Sark boutent sur 64 ans mais il
aurait l'essentiel dans ces affaires là
vous savez bien c'est de prendre en
compte la diversité des situations tout
le monde voit bien la situation des
femmes avec les carrières hachées tout
le monde voit bien la question de la
pénibilité tout le monde voit bien que
des gens peuvent faire plus longtemps
des travaux regardez moi je suis
sénateur c'est pas un métier c'est une
fonction mais j'ai dépassé l'âge mais en
même temps je vais arrêter d'ailleurs je
vous rassure mais je vais arrêter parce
que je ne vais pas me représenter en
septembre mais il y a certains métiers
dans lesquels on peut travailler plus
longuement donc il y avait certainement
des
compromisés sur ce qu'il a dit hier au
syndicat vous avez entendu dans le
journal la réaction des syndicats pour
vous il a fait une faute de parler comme
ça des syndicats je crois moi je crois
que il y a eu un manque d'ouverture de
sa part parce que
quand on exerce le pouvoir il y a des
moments il faut savoir tendre la main et
je dirais même qu'il y a des moments il
faut peut-être savoir reculer ou faire
des compromis me semble-t-il parce
qu'aujourd'hui on a vraiment le
sentiment d'une fracture entre le
Président le pouvoir exécutif et un
grand nombre de Français
il n'a pas reculé du tout hier il a dit
souhaiter que le texte entre en vigueur
avant la fin de l'année sauf évidemment
si le Conseil constitutionnel le censure
vous avez fait des recours vous la
gauche les parlementaires de gauche
devant le Conseil constitutionnel vous
pensez que ces recourseront vraiment en
mesure d'empêcher l'entrée en vigueur du
texte je le pense je pense que ce texte
a été indument je dis bien indûment
présenté comme une loi de finance
rectificative alors que ce n'est pas une
loi de finance simplement il y a dans la
Constitution un dispositif qui permet
que les lois de finance qu'il s'agit du
budget de l'État ou qu'il s'agisse du
PLFSS des financements de la sécurité
sociale soit adopté le 31 décembre ça
évite vous savez sous la Quatrième
République on arrêtait les pendules bon
ça permet d'avoir un budget à la fin de
l'année
et cela a été utilisé par confort par le
gouvernement pour restreindre le débat
en 50 jours donc je crois que c'est une
utilisation indue d'un article qui est
fait pour autre chose
d'autre part il y a une accumulation de
procédures extrêmement irrimante je
pense à l'utilisation de l'article 44 de
la Constitution je pense à l'utilisation
de l'article 38 du Règlement du Sénat
bon samedi peut-être pas grand chose à
ceux qui nous celles et ceux qui nous
regardent mais ça veut dire concrètement
que au bout d'un certain temps il y a eu
le vote bloqué c'est-à-dire qu'on
pouvait dire tout ce qu'on voulait dans
l'hémicycle il m'a vu y avoir de vote
donc il y avait plus qu'un vote sur un
texte avec les amendements adoptés par
le gouvernement en même temps on nous a
dit les explications de vote et ne peut
y avoir qu'une seule par groupe en même
temps on nous a dit pour les amendements
vous pouvez voir un pour un compte donc
du coup vous misez sur une
fera ce qu'il jugera de voir faire je ne
peux pas prédire mais je dis qu'il y a
des arguments forts et le premier
argument c'est l'utilisation indue d'un
texte ce qui est relatif aux lois de
finance pour une loi qui n'est pas une
loi de finance alors lors de son
allocution Emmanuel Macron a demandé à
Elisabeth borne de bâtir un programme
législatif on va voir en quoi ça
consiste et les détails avec notre
journaliste parlementaire Audrey
[Musique]
bonjour et Audrey hier le président a
esquissé une nouvelle manière de
fonctionner pour éviter l’écueil de la
majorité relative à l'Assemblée
nationale oui c'était destiné tout au
long de l'interview alors on va essayer
de tout rassembler les journalistes lui
ont évidemment posé la question celle
sur les risques d'immobilisme après la
séquence sur les retraites et pour y
faire face Emmanuel Macron à une
solution il a demandé à sa première
ministre Elisabeth borne ceci
pour avoir la fois moins de textes de
loi des textes plus courts plus clairs
pour aussi changer les choses pour nos
compatriotes de manière plus tangible
c'est tout ne passe pas par la loi et
donc dans ce contexte il faut agir au
service de nos priorités de nos
compatriotes le faire de manière très
concrète avec les élus sur le terrain
avec les services de l'État et tout ne
passe pas par la loi et on passe trop
par la loi dans notre République
j'ai coupé la phrase au milieu parce
qu'elle était un peu longue mais on
comprend que le chef de l'État trouve
que les lois sont trop fourre-tout trop
bavardes et pour cela il s'appuie sur
des avis réguliers du des conseils
d'État et du Conseil constitutionnel qui
dit justement que les lois sont souvent
trop fourre-tout on comprend donc le
président n'exclut pas de passer plus
par décret et par règlement il a donné
un premier exemple l'ouverture sur le
territoire de 200 brigades de
gendarmerie en ajoutant pas besoin de
loi pour faire ça François Patriat le
président du groupe de la majorité
présidentielle au Sénat a d'ailleurs
fait le service
après-vente de cette idée dans la foulée
de l'interview du président écouté il y
a des mesures concrètes des mesures
concrètes tout l'environnement les
choses la vie des français on peut le
faire par décret et pourquoi pas le
faire alors que normalement aujourd'hui
on annonce des lois qui n'ont défait
bénéfiques pour les Français que deux
ans ou trois ans après moi je pense que
c'est une aujourd'hui c'est une solution
de sagesse
ils ont raison légifère
il faudrait fermer le Parlement
finalement nous ça ne sert plus
puisqu'on peut faire des petites mesures
non soyons sérieux selon sérieux je vais
vous dire quelque chose
que vous ne savez pas encore j'ai été
hier à 19h45 à la Conférence des
présidents du Sénat donc on nous a
annoncé que le texte sur l'immigration
était retiré de l'ordre du jour si bien
que l'année prochaine il n'y a plus
l'ordre du jour sauf les questions
d'actualité bon et on a posé la question
au ministre monsieur Riester qui a dit
il y aura des petits textes sur
l'immigration
dans le futur pour le moment c'est en
réflexion c'est en réflexion et alors on
a donné la parole à tous les présidents
de groupe et aucun n'a souscrit
parce que
il a été dit par plusieurs présidents de
groupes différents il n'y a pas trois
politiques de l'immigration il n'y a pas
une politique de l'immigration un
morceau il y a pas un texte qu'on va
faire voter par la gauche un petit texte
et un autre petit texte ou moyen texte
par la droite ça n'a pas de sens et je
vais vous dire que j'ai participé aussi
au débat en commission sur la loi
immigration le projet de loi immigration
tel qu'il nous a été présenté
franchement
sont arrivés en tête du texte regardez
dix amendements
dont je considère qu'ils sont des
amendements anti immigrés c'est à dire
que le la majorité LR a durci
considérablement le texte alors que nous
neions pas que la France est une terre
d'accueil on va revenir jugement
sur la question d'Audrey sur le
Parlement et sur les lois
sur le Parlement et sur les lois il se
dit en coulisses vous allez voir si on
va voir si vous nous confirmez pardon
que on aurait peut-être un projet de loi
sur les mesures plus consensuelles sur
le projet de loi immigration et puis des
initiatives parlementaires pour les
sujets plus clivants est-ce que vous le
confirmez et est-ce que c'est la bonne
manière non je dis non et je peux vous
dire que tous les présidents de groupe
pratiquement enfin ou presque tous on
dit la même chose écoutez il y a une
politique immigration on peut être pour
on peut être contre nous nous sommes
plus nous sommes contre la loi telle
qu'elle a été présentée mais surtout
durci par le groupe LR il est évident il
est évident qu'il ne pouvait pas y avoir
d'accord entre la majorité relative du
président de la République et le groupe
LR sur l'immigration ça monsieur
Retailleau l'a dit en large et en
travers donc plutôt que de prendre une
nouvelle baigne et si je peux parler
comme ça après les retraites ils ont dit
il vaut mieux reculer ça je comprends
tout à fait mais croire qu'on va régler
cette question par des petits morceaux
de textes les uns après les autres qu'il
s'agisse de projets de loi ou de
proposition de loi inspirée etc non mais
il y avait une jambe droite et une jambe
gauche danse dans ce projet de loyer il
y avait la partie Gérald Darmanin à
partir
par exemple la partie Olivier du socle
avec notamment les titres de séjour pour
ces travailleurs dans les métiers en
tension est-ce que ça vous le voterez
c'est la limite du en même temps il y a
naturellement des mesures tout à fait
nécessaire je pense tout simplement mais
non regardez les hôteliers et
restaurateurs
je pense il y a eu un ami tu Loiret
président des hôteliers restaurateurs
qui il nous a quittés ont fait ces
obsèques de moi je pense à lui
ils attendent de pouvoir recruter du
personnel et de valider l'autorisation
des personnels qui sont là bon il y a
des mesures absolument nécessaires et je
regrette qu'on ne puisse pas prendre ces
mesures nécessaires en revanche
parce que vous savez que derrière il y
aura un texte qui durcit mais en
revanche je vous le dis franchement je
crois que c'est les limites du en même
temps il ne peut pas y avoir trois
politiques sur l'immigration et moi je
suis partisan d'une politique qui disent
l'admin l'immigration c'est une
constante dans la vie de la France on a
toujours accueilli des personnes venant
d'ailleurs je vais vous dire une chose
on va en accueillir davantage avec sans
doute les phénomènes climatiques des
gens vont devoir fuir leur pays et la
misère et alors ça demande certainement
de la rigueur de l'exigence je le dis
mais ça demande aussi un sens de
l'accueil et de l'intégration donc je
suis en désaccord avec les 10 ou 15 ou
20 amendements qui ont été voté en
commission beaucoup et les trouver qui
sont des amendements totalement
restrictifs et répressif moi nous nous
n'aurions jamais voté la version de la
loi immigration
ni initiale et surtout pas telle qu'elle
a été durcie par la droite donc on
atteint les limites du en même temps
soyons clairs mais d'où peut-être la
volonté du Président de la République de
diviser ce texte en plusieurs petits
textes est-ce que du coup que vous a dit
Franck Riester si la quasi-totalité des
présidents de groupe du Sénat hier se
sont opposés à cette division
mais ce que je crois c'est que on va
voir le courage de ces opinions moi j'ai
des opinions claires sur l'immigration
qui ne sont certainement pas celles de
LR et je soutiendrai avec mes collègues
tout ce qui va dans le sens de nos
valeurs et aussi d'une exigence d'une
rigueur qui sont nécessaires je dis les
deux mais nous refuserons le déport vers
des mesures essentiellement répressives
telles qu'elles sont apparues dans les
amendements du groupe LR je redonne la
parole Audrey sur ce qui va se passer au
Sénat la semaine prochaine qu'est-ce qui
a été décidé hier en conférence des
présidents puisque le texte immigration
occupait la totalité de la Science
Publique et que les coaching après midi
les questions donc nous aurons le temps
de travailler sur les dossiers de fond
donc créant ces sciences public à part
les questions d'actualité Audrey sur les
ordonnances c'est le texte plus court
finalement on a toujours dit que les
lois étaient trop fourre-tout trop
gloubi-bouba on en a parlé c'est
peut-être une bonne idée finalement de
faire des plus petits lois des plus
petits textes oui ce sont des paroles de
merci Audrey à tout à l'heure dans le
club va revenir sur l'intervention
d'Emmanuel Macron avec vous et la
réaction des réaction des syndicats
merci beaucoup Audrey à tout à l'heure
on parle du Parti socialiste pour ça on
va aller du côté de l'Occitanie
retrouver Eric berger bonjour Eric merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous rédacteurs en
chef adjoint de la Dépêche du Midi et
Eric il y a une législative partielle
dimanche dans la première
circonscription de l'Ariège et la
situation est plutôt tendue à gauche oui
bonjour Oriane en effet c'est un scrutin
très intéressant qu'un petit résonance
nationale on va effectivement revoter
dans la première circonscription de
l'Ariège et la situation y est très
tendue entre les deux principaux
candidats de gauche alors petit rappel
au mois de juin dernier lors des
législatives c'est Bénédicte taurine
candidate et les fils soutenu par la
nups qu'il avait emporté face à au
second tour à la candidate Renaissance
Anne-Sophie Tribout 55% des contre 45
mais au premier tour elle avait elle
était en tête avec 33% des voix et le
candidat du Rassemblement national
Jean-Marc Garnier avait raté pour lui
petites voix la qualification pour le
second tour et surtout ce qui nous
intéresse dans cette législative c'est
la présence d'une candidature socialiste
dissidente même si la candidate refuse
ce terme
il s'agit d'une candidate élue locale
Martine Froget qui a décidé comme en
juin dernier de se présenter contre la
députée sortante et les filles nues
Martin Froget avait réalisé 18% des voix
ce qui était un bon score en juin
dernier dans un contexte difficile alors
vous savez qu'ici en Occitanie il y a de
vives tensions entre pro anti-nubs au
sein du PS c'est pas un hasard si en fin
d'année dernière lors des élections
internes au PS Nicolas Maillard
Rossignol a réalisé
meilleur score nationaux dans la région
puisque vous savez que Carole Delga la
présidente du conseil régional est
opposée farouchement opposée à cet
accord PS et les filles et dans cette
première circonscription de l'arrière il
y aura donc une candidature dissidente
Martine Froget et soutenu par quasiment
toute la fédération du PS ariégeois il y
a également le soutien de elle a aussi
le soutien de la présidente du conseil
départemental de l'Ariège une socialiste
et bien entendu de Carole Delga la
présidente du conseil régional durant
cette campagne plusieurs poids lourds au
nationaux sont venus au soutien de leurs
différents candidats
par exemple Bernard Cazeneuve l'ancien
ministre socialiste de François Hollande
est venu défendre la candidature de
Martin Froget carole delgas est aussi
affiché à ses côtés et puis au RN il y a
eu Louis Aliot il y a quelques jours et
demain
devrait venir Marine Le Pen pour
soutenir son candidat qui espère bien
profiter de la situation dans ce
contexte de fortes riposte contre la
réforme des des retraites donc on suivra
évidemment avec beaucoup d'attention ces
résultats dimanche soir et ce match à
gauche entre les deux candidats
socialistes et la candidate et les
filles soutenues par la nuque il y a eu
aussi eu Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui est venu
mardi dans un meeting pour soutenir son
candidat alors j'avais une question pour
votre invité jean-Pierre Sueur bonjour
comment vous que pensez-vous cette
situation un peu particulière et c'est
dissidente et ses candidatures
socialistes et comment vous vous
positionnez par rapport à la nups est-ce
que les socialistes doivent
obligatoirement suivre les consignes
nationales et est-ce que vous comprenez
que certains socialistes refusent cette
cette alliance écoutez c'est très clair
moi je suis socialiste et je soutiens la
candidate socialiste c'est simple alors
donc Martine
mais pourquoi il y a eu un accord
pour les législatives
l'année dernière
et tout le monde a convenu que cet
accord était profondément déséquilibré
dans la plupart des départements les
socialistes n'ont pu présenter qu'un
candidat quelquefois aucun alors que si
vous regardez la carte de France vous
voyez bien que pour ce qui est de
l'implantation locale dans les communes
nous sommes beaucoup plus représentés
où nous pouvions être candidats sur 577
donc qu'est-ce que nous avons dit au
congrès de Marseille du PS qu'il fallait
rééquilibrer c'est tout à fait évident
et là nous sommes dans l'Ariège qui est
une terre profondément socialiste
profondément donc je regrette tout à
fait
que notre
premier secrétaire il y en a deux
puisqu'il y a aussi notre ami Mayer
rossignol qui est permis
nationale parce que
ça a été l'occasion de dire après un
congrès de Marseille on a essayé même
dans la difficulté de faire l'union
puisque il y a des points de vue
divergents dans l'Ariège voilà vous la
moitié du parti vous êtes exclu du
secrétariat national je trouve ça
vraiment dommageable je le dis
franchement je trouve ça dommageable et
par conséquent je comprends tout à fait
mes amis de l'Ariège qui soutiennent
madame breux Frogier et moi je la
soutiens comme une bonne partie des
socialistes
la grande majorité des socialistes de
l'Ariège de la région et beaucoup dans
toute la France j'aurais voulu qu'on en
fasse pas une affaire nationale et que
nous puissions continuer ce que nous
avons fait par exemple dans mon
département du Loiret où les socialistes
restent unis parce qu'on a décidé
l'Union et qu'on trouve que l'Union et
ce qui permet d'avancer est-ce que à un
moment il ne faut pas que vous et ceux
qui sont sur la ligne de Nicolas Mayer
Rossignol elle est au bout de la
démarche et qu'il y ait yes et bien
est-ce que est-ce que vous avez envie
par exemple de vous ranger derrière
quelqu'un comme Bernard Cazeneuve non
écoutez je crois que la coupure en deux
du PS serait une mauvaise chose moi je
suis pour l'unité je l'ai toujours été
ce parti est un parti pluralisme et je
connais son histoire depuis quelques
décennies il y a eu beaucoup de beaucoup
d'épisodes dans cette histoire et dans
l'histoire du Parti socialiste depuis
1905 voyez je ne vais pas développer
parce qu'il faudrait une autre émission
même plusieurs il y a eu beaucoup de
débats et c'est bien un parti où il y a
des débats mais je ne crois pas qu'une
rupture serait une bonne chose et
d'ailleurs j'ai dit à Bernard Cazeneuve
et je le redis j'aurais préféré qu'il
reste dans le Parti socialiste
merci Jean-Pierre merci beaucoup à vous
d'avoir été notre merci Eric berger
merci Eric berger merci à vous de votre
invitation et on monte votre une Macron
ne
va pas la Dépêche du Midi
merci beaucoup Eric berger merci
d'avoir été notre invité ce matin